I did occasion this is station twelve faith and and B.P. Will continue in a few seconds time and to fight education.
This was in the early fifty's. And I will also check that. Now. Also there were. I think Linfox was.
Before he was married this what. But speaking about metaphor.
He was the black sheep of the very wealthy family more because of his politics and I think when he was he went to.
He spent a lot of time in Hungary and he was in the ME. The British Army I think.
And spoke fluently very bright person. I think he got his degree from Cambridge. But I wouldn't say for sure.
But he was an extremely humble person but a very gifted person and I should lend you some of his or
when your piano comes you can come up here and play some of his music
and that lute hanging on the wall in the lounge room was a present from to your heart. Well he and Katie.
Were the black sheep you know and they didn't have close friendships relationships with their own family
and they used to go and visit the only mother.
But it drove Katie mad because the kids couldn't drop a crumb on the floor and all that kind of thing.
And when I got to know some little better. They came and had their holidays with us. The Trenches forest.
Well drawn first at this conference chairman. Great personality. It's a tragedy. He. This was never captured on video.
And he good looking guy great. For music. Playing the lute he made. He playing the flute.
He made record is an amazing person and he wrote future for poetry.
Person Where you see I met you on the air with this conference. I met Steve and Mary Smith.
I remember Steven coming and visiting us at French's forest and we lived on my road at that time.
And so he put a little note on his shoulders and carried her backwards
and forwards to the car which was parked about three hundred meters away from my house because the road was rough. And.
People from all writers from all over Australia. I have a feeling that Rodney Hall was.
Just beginning his career as a writer but I must talk to Rodney about this because he leaned
and took him under his wing in prison. And helped Rodney I know that.
Yes and I did feel that I could possibly put a sentence together. I was always a great letter writer.
And like my mother was a great later writer.
I found out later the other day which you'd written to my sister Catherine in the fifty's.
But she was she had this stepsister who lived at the foot of man. On the trade and.
That was a seven mile away from where we live but they wrote to each other everybody.
And mother would sit and wait for that later to come and then she'd sit down straight away
and get me to post a letter writing was very important in a family. My sister was a great letter writer.
And I have many letters from my brother John. And the wonderful habit of writing letters.
And I've just been looking at my file of her letters. It's just beautiful. It is wonderful.
Well I thought Look forget about the books and then. I did a lot of things to help the writers in different way.
I recall when there was another conference which John manifold. That was held in the city.
And like William Hatfill do or do you did you read any if you know well he's an Australian like Mike.
And I have he was the brother in law or of MARGARET FULTON.
And his wife and with his wife he lived on the whole little house and I would often go up and visit them.
And Margaret was living with them at one stage and we'd take turns of fire at night
and you know I can always remember saying. Time for a little to think get something in the half and and my next.
I could go into the fuel I haven't. And we quote fish and cook the fish particularly. Just beautiful.
Well they'll have to fill out and his wife were at this other conference of writers that was held in the city
and it was cool to get a publishing house off the ground for basically left wing writers. And it became it was.
And it became known as the Australian book the years.
Australian society I think and I published Australian writers particularly it was Frank how do you.
And I attended that conference and after it was over I can always remember Bill
and Gene saying we're going to the pub for the way in class or a street. At the pub very big old place for a drink.
Come on event. So I was with Bill and Jane and Frank had me.
And John Mann a fellow couple of others us about us and we were.
Now none of these blokes had a tie on and you couldn't get into the lounge without a tie
and the only place women could drink would be in the law all had to go into the lounge
and away to whoever it was wouldn't let the main. But there was one person who had a tie on.
And I think it was the boss here. So he went up with his own and took it over and gave it to me.
And this is what went on and eventually we got them all in the door. Yeah.
And so they were talking about the Australasian book society that was it.
It had already been found that was the last session of the conference that had already been founded and.
Became very involved in it because I was a devout reader. But like I was reading. Classics.
Like when Hans and I were first married. If one was reading a book one would never interrupt.
It had the highest priority. In our place.
And I said Well forming this society will it mean one I have good writers who wouldn't be published by other houses in
some cases because of me which happened. Now we are able to be published.
And I said oh yes this is what it's all about you know.
Well it's not for me really to go into the history of the last relation books
but I can say this that it took up a big part of my life
and life because we would often make the visiting writers who would come into state at the airport because so few
people had cars. We had a car would pick them up and we'd actors to show for.
And take them to the various meetings that would be organized for the launching of the invokes
and they were all cottage. Lectures meetings. Absolutely fascinating.
You know and these houses up there on the Hill and narrow would open up and receive the both of us.
I was just going to. These writers experience.
Real discrimination from the government and I know that they were all a bit.
Well I mean you will lose a great circle of people who have bonded because of your political views as well
but to any of the writers you met at that time they experienced discrimination. Oh yes oh yes.
Rightists experienced discrimination like me in C.S. Would not permit. Graham to be given to. But he gave it to.
Quadrant because quadrant had all the right wing people writing for it was found and passed even Mary Smith
and he was the red. Main series was concerned. So make sure that they didn't get any funding.
I've got to come back to that sometime after I've spoken to my pastor about it because that's a very important part of
my life and also very important part of Australian history that no one has ever recorded.
My God I have to do this book. Just because.